[Aplausos]
[Música]
é mais aberta aqui é boa noite pra todo
mundo
bom quando me convidaram pra fazer essa
fala aqui é primeiro fiquei sentindo
muitas coisas muito parecidas com o que
estou sentindo agora aqui na minha
barriguinha
depois eu fiquei pensando que eu poderia
falar porque eu nunca tinha feito nunca
fiz isso antes e aí eu decidi dividir
com vocês é o momento recente e muito
importante pra mim que foi um momento em
que eu percebi que eu realmente
precisava lidar com as minhas
vulnerabilidades e com as minhas
fragilidades de uma maneira diferente de
como eu vinha lidando porque não era bom
e então fiz uma lista de situações em
que o identificava que essas
vulnerabilidades gritavam mais apareciam
mais e quando cheguei no final dessa
lista eu percebi que todas elas tinham a
mesma raiz que era uma sensação muito
profunda de medo e de insegurança
eu pensei bom então eu entendi que eu
sou uma pessoa que sente muito medo sem
muitas inseguranças
portanto também uma pessoa facilmente
paralisava eu mas a verdade é que eu
entendia muito pouco sobre esse
sentimento eu sei eu sentia ele era
muito nessa região mas muito pouco
compreendido e eu pensei que para eu
conseguir lidar com eles eu precisava
realmente entender de onde é que eles
vinham e eu entendi que eu precisava
olhar pra minha história de uma maneira
diferente como nunca tinha olhado olhar
mesmo honestamente com muita coragem
apesar de todos os medos
e esse não é um movimento simples porque
quando a gente resolve olhar para a
nossa história verdadeiramente agente
revisita muitos lugares lugares difíceis
lugares de dor então pra mim já começou
assim tipo meu deus então vamos lá vamos
olhar para essa história
quando eu fiz esse exercício eu fiquei
muito surpresa porque eu percebi que de
fato na minha vida tinha acontecido os
eventos e acontecimentos episódios
coisas grandes coisas que legitimavam
realmente a presença desses medos e
dessas inseguranças
de fato na minha vida tinha antes do
case ons que seria muito comum que esses
medos ainda ecoassem em mim quando eu
percebi que isso era muito legítimo a
existência desse sentimento de medo e
insegurança
eu tive um momento de muita tristeza
assim que foi o momento que eu percebi o
quanto eu jogava contra mim porque
quando eu sentia esse medo ea
insegurança e não conseguia acolher isso
eu sentia raiva eu sentia raiva de mim
eu sentia muita raiva de mim assim eu
sentia como se eu fosse uma pessoa fraca
eu sentia como se fosse uma pessoa menor
e eu pensei puxa já é tudo tão difícil
eu já fui submetido a situações tão
loucas que capacidade incrível e
assustadora é essa de auto julgamento é
autopunição e e poxa já era tudo tão
difícil talvez eu devesse ser a primeira
pessoa a me abraçar
diante dessas situações e não ficar
contra mim que era o que eu tinha hábito
de fazer e que era muito cruel exaustivo
e num me levava pra lugar nenhum a não
ser ficar no mesmo lugar se discutindo
e eu fiquei muito triste quando eu
percebi isso e eu tive um momento quase
ritualístico assim onde eu parei pra
realmente pedi desculpas pra mim mesma
pedi desculpas por nunca ter conseguido
perceber essas coisas antes pedir
desculpa por nunca ter conseguido
enxergar o quanto eu precisava de mim
mesma me acolhendo diante de sentimentos
e eu pensei 'bom eu passei e vencer está
então agora eu vou tentar lidar de uma
maneira diferente com as coisas mas como
é que faz isso nem como é que o rock
então agora eu tô pronto como eu lido
com isso e é muito curioso porque não
têm como lidar com o medo sem a presença
do medo sem que ele esteja presente
então eu não tinha eu não poderia fazer
nada a não ser ficar esperando o medo
aparecer
a sensação aquela que eu conheço que
acontecem muitas coisas aqui dentro
e obviamente um dia ele chegou e aí eu
estava no camarim
prestes a fazer um show muito importante
com a banda mais bonita
faltavam uns 40 minutos para o show
começou aquela sensação física assim de
medo e e é muito louco porque o medo ele
produz
achei muito interessante diz que adora
falou que o medo ele produz cenários
muito bizarros e que você perde um pouco
a noção do que é real e do que não é
real e nesse momento que eu estava no
camarim e quarenta minutos antes do show
eu tava sucumbindo a esse universo
bizarro que o meu que a minha cabeça
cria diante do medo de um sentimento de
incapacidade de um sentimento de
horrível e quando estava quase entrando
nesse furacão eu tive um segundo de
sanidade e pensei acho que é esse
momento
acho que é esse momento que eu preciso
tentar olhar para esse medo um pouco
mais de cima
assim e não sabia muito o que fazer
então pensei vou ficar fazendo perguntas
agora aqui e ali fiz uma série de
perguntas assim tipo cara eu tô nervosa
com o show está tudo bem com o show a
passagem de som foi ok a parte técnica
toque a parte artística tá ok eu sei as
músicas e fui fazendo uma série de
perguntas é para tentar mapear mesmo
essa sensação
até que cheguei num momento dessas de
respostas que eu cheguei nesse momento
que eu entendi que o que me dava medo
naquele dia naquela coxinha antes do
show era esse sentimento de exposição e
aí eu pensei mas puxa eu acho que deve
ser normal sentir medo de exposição
porque é o que é difícil se expor mesmo
é difícil estar aqui é difícil em cima
de um palco com o microfone na mão eo
meu trabalho passa por um lugar à
disposição e eu tenho dentro da minha
história de vida episódios de exposição
não programados que foram inclusive
bastante violentos assim então acho que
tá tudo bem senti medo da exposição acho
legítimo sentimento da exposição
quando eu entendi isso já me deu uma
sensação de um pouquinho diferente mas
ainda estava sem saber como é que eu
consegui entrar no palco para fazer o
show eu pense e eu estava me sentindo
muito pequenininha diante desse medo e
eu pensei 'bom eu preciso fazer alguma
coisa para me conectar comigo porque só
me conectando comigo eu vou conseguir
tipo crescer um pouquinho e ficar pelo
menos mais do tamanho desse medo pra
conseguir fazer esse show porque é o meu
trabalho inclusive não tinha como
desistir e eu pensei o que eu poderia
fazer para me conectar comigo e eu tenho
eu sempre quando eu preciso me conectar
comigo eu penso o que eu amo eu preciso
fazer uma coisa que eu ame muito porque
as coisas que a gente ama fazem a gente
voltar pra gente e eu pensei num camarim
falta 40 minutos
ou eu vou dançar que eu amo dançar e
dança na sala da minha casa todos os
dias é uma coisa que me na terra me traz
pra mim e aí nem falei com os meninos só
botei fone e foi para um camarim
escondida e eu nem sei a mesma música
muitas vezes dancei dança e dança e
dança e dança e dança e dancei até que
eu fui sentindo que de alguma maneira
estava crescendo um pouco e aí em algum
momento eu olhei pro meu medo e disser
que estamos do mesmo tamanho acho que
acho que agora eu consigo e atirei meus
sapatos
entrei no palco nós 21 eo medo já do
tamanho mas justo e e foi maravilhoso
porque durante o show sem que eu
percebesse ele já não estava mais ali e
foi uma noite incrível e acho que foi e
é um pouco assim também agora nesse
momento foi um processo parecido pra mim
tá aqui falando sobre isso mas estou
muito feliz também de ter encontrado as
minhas maneiras de vencer esse medo de
hoje está podendo dividir essas
histórias com vocês muito obrigado
obrigada
e aí como é isso que eu faço na vida e
no meio de tantos medos eu descobri que
é isso que eu amo o que eu faço da vida
é vou dividir outra coisa com vocês
el che vi medo eu quis escrita
[Música]
eu quis escrita
a ew que a escrita
[Música]
eu quis grita
ai ai ai
quantos olhos me olham olha o meu
coração em pedaços aqui quantos dedos
juntam meus cacos quanto os braços botam
minha cabeça sobre o peito me dá a mão
na minha mão está aqui me dá a mão na
minha mão está aqui me dá a mão na minha
mão está aqui me dá a mão na minha mão
está aqui eu que grita
a inteira
estou aqui